so season one was a real slow build for
the fans to see you guys in action to
see your powers get together whatever
gonna see you actually like really
kicking some butt like really be a cloak
and dagger doing your thing I mean I
think towards the end of the season
definitely our powers are way more
enhanced and I think as you know the
season progresses everything just sort
of evolves and hopefully this next
season in season two will be able to
like dive a little further into what our
powers are and how we can control them
and I mean I really think that they're
still trying to figure it out you know
they're really confused on what they're
doing but I think they're sort of
started to give me the hang of it
towards the end of the season which is
nice
who in your family is the most excited
that you guys are part of the whole
Marvel thing no literally like
everything that our social media page
posts post on her Instagram that's
amazing she's a Google Alerts
I'd say my dad and my brother you know I
mean growing up my dad and my brother
and I am you know my mom and sister but
it was like the three of us my dad my
brother and me that would just like be
like obsessed to go see like any Marvel
movie and even with the shows you know
what we we all live in different places
so it's nice to sort of like have
something to like bond over and talk
about and I'll you know watch our show
separately and then like come together
and just like geek out over it it's well
you guys like it's awesome to getting
season two but a couple years ago you
know when you're sitting in that theater
watching those movies could you foresee
yourself being these superheroes is
exciting and you think about but you
don't really realize that it could get
Amelia thing that this could be a life
for you so yeah we're really excited and
the fact that we get to portray these
two characters who are so special and
unique to the Marvel Universe and you
know I mean we both feel very lucky to
have this place and to be able to tell
their stories yeah
and I mean it's I always say this is the
perfect show for right now because you
know these these young people that are
watching the show are going to grow up
seeing this connection between a black
person and a white person and a black
male and about a white female so it's
it's gonna become the new norm and and I
feel like that's so important right now
and yeah just to be a part of a Marvel
show that actually cares enough to speak
about what's really going on is such an
honor how do you prepare for something
like comic-con does anybody tell you
beforehand like this is what you do you
do this how you get to its running
around back for all the people yes and
no I feel like we it's been hyped up for
years for us and even you know when we
shot the first episode last year in
February
people are like already talking about
comic-con oh we haven't even finished
the season yet let's slow our roll but
you know you hear about it and you read
about it but you don't really know what
it's like and see you experience it on
your own and it's been so much fun so
far we've received a lot of awesome
positive responses from the fans and to
be able to connect with them face to
face versus over social media is like so
epic so we're really happy to be here
yeah awesome well thank you so much guys
season soon